mark Stein covers the NBA for the New
York time so where do we stand with fact
as opposed to fiction right now mark
well by the end of the night we'll have
much more fact because LeBron has until
11:59 Eastern so formally up in or opt
out in the last year of his cab contract
I think the whole NBA world safe to say
expect him to opt out and actually
become a free agent but obviously that
would throw Wake the curveball if he
decided to opt in and suddenly you know
we're all preparing for something else
but I I think there's anything close to
a safe bet here I would anticipate that
he does opt out and actually becomes a
free agent for the third time yeah I
can't imagine that he would trust dan
Gilbert to help facilitate a move the
next move for him but the other part of
this is Marc it is LeBron going to the
Lakers and not depleting the Lakers if
there's a sign in trade but then if you
get to the Lakers and you're trying to
get Kawhi then Kawhi is gonna deplete
the Lakers there so everybody wants a
super team I don't know if it's gonna be
a super team if LeBron and Kawhi go
there your thoughts if liberal goes
there it will ultimately be a super team
I think the only question will be how
long does it take yeah now it might not
be instant and I've actually changed my
position on this I was originally one of
those who would say there's no way he
goes there by himself but you know what
he he already has a home or homes there
I think he might even have to his family
spends a lot of time in LA if the family
says you know what let's just go live in
LA we want to try something different
why wouldn't he go there and and believe
that over time I have to believe that
one or two good players are gonna want
to play with LeBron James because the
Lakers have so many young players that
teams would love they're not gonna have
trouble finding trade offers if they
want to make the likes of Kuzma and
Ingram available so eventually there
will be plenty of talent around LeBron
James it might not it just might not
happen in
year one the Spurs element involved in
this that do they do the Spurs how much
leverage does san antonio have you know
it's hard to gauge exactly but you know
the the pressure is not on them right
now I mean they have until February 2019
if they want to drag this thing all the
way out if they keep Kawai into next
season then is that as a inch closer to
the trade deadline that's when they have
to make a decision because you can't let
the deadline go and Kauai still on your
team and then he opts out and just
leaves you in free agency so the Spurs
don't have to make a deal now but you
know they have more leverage than the
Lakers as we speak because they don't
have to make a deal today but I was told
yesterday in pretty strong terms they're
ready to move on they know that this
relationship is mmm it can't be repaired
this is not you know this is beyond pop
and Kauai meeting face to face and and
fixing it as pop was able to do with
LaMarcus Aldridge last summer it's it
it's pretty much come on at this point
what's your best guess on how this plays
out if I'm talking to you at the
beginning of this season I'm not gonna
hold you to this but at the beginning of
the season LeBron is where Kauai is
where and Paul George is where okay
these are predictions right aggregators
these are predictions yes not reported
fact I think Paul George stays in
Oklahoma City that's really the moat
with the ways the momentum has been
building that way for the last month I
think that's the safest bet as we speak
I'm going to say Lakers for LeBron I
don't say it with great conviction
I think the Cavs are still in his
thinking and I know that's been kind of
your tout here for the last few weeks so
I I do think the Cavs you know staying
is not off the table for him but I would
lean Lakers on LeBron and then Kawhi I'm
gonna say traded I can't give you a
destination yet I don't think we know
the destination but I I
do believe that the Spurs will trade him
in the near future but it's not a given
it's Los Angeles even though he wants to
go no no it's I don't think it's a given
I mean that you know Philadelphia badly
wants him
Boston is sniffing around the Clippers
would love to have him you know that
there are there are dice rollers in this
league who are not gonna be swayed by
okuu I want to be a Laker well we're out
I mean you saw that a year ago with
Oklahoma City
you know the Thunder didn't even contact
George's camp before they made that
trade they just did it they you know
they you know that is on one hand you
say well okay it wasn't that big of a
dice roll that the Thunder didn't even
give up a draft pick but that's a pretty
that's a pretty gutsy move for a team to
trade for a player of Paul George's
stature who is one year away from free
agency and not even check to see how he
feels about Oklahoma City they just did
it and there there are other teams that
operate in that manner
mark good stuff have a great weekend and
thanks for joining us anytime
good talking that's a mark Stein covers
the NBA for the New York Times for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]